[Music]
girl scouts from the news have you heard
about this andy i i've heard of girl
scouts
creepy out of context the uh
you're like boo radley over there yeah i
know of them
the girl scouts turns 100 this year not
great yeah
but here's the thing
a bit of a controversy one indiana
lawmaker is refusing to honor the
occasion because he says the girl scouts
are quote a tactical arm of planned
parenthood and that they promote a
homosexual lifestyle
the girl scouts
yeah i heard that i thought i thought
this guy's crazy then i saw some of the
new girl scout cookies they're selling
and i changed my mind he might be on to
something i swear to god check it out
there's roe v wafers right there
there's heather has two malomars
there's our cookies ourselves
there's dolce de long-term roommates
[Laughter]
they're sado mints now i'm sorry i
didn't
[Applause]
that's a real one yeah
they are not good no
there's this one lady fingers in lady
parts
[Applause]
anyone who wants to leave should go now
and finally savannah smiles because
she's having a lesbian affair with a
planned parenthood doctor that's a good
question
you